welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka mr boombastic tell me
fantastic and with doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness coming soon
there's a lot of things i want to talk
about you've probably read the reports
online discussing who's going to be in
the movie and over the weekend john
krasinski's name was trending all over
twitter just because fans wanted to see
him sharp as reid richards there's a ton
of possibilities for new and returning
characters and throughout this video
we're going to be going over our top
picks for who we'd like to see come into
the mcu now just in the same way that no
way home pulled across actors like
andrew garfield and toby maguire i think
that the multiverse of madness will also
bring across several characters that
we've seen before from other franchises
this was handed out in the logo scene of
the multiverse of madness trailer which
fractured and showed several variations
of the marvel studios one typically when
the logo comes in it's pretty
straightforward however we got an almost
mirror dimension take on this one in
which we could see other styles in it
from other franchises there was one that
was used by sony and also the one from
the x-men fox franchise making me think
that several of those characters will be
showing up now if you cast your mind
back to last year all of us were eagerly
anticipating evan peters showing up in
one division it was reported pretty
early on that he'd be playing
quicksilver but come the end of the
season marvel did a bait and switch to
the point that doing a ralph bona is now
considered a term that means tricking
the fans what's weird is that even
before the release of one division my
wife was constantly talking about
ralph's boner so she must have an inside
scoop somewhere and that would explain
why she's constantly sneaking out at
night anyway i think that the multiverse
of madness is the perfect film to make
things right and with wanda feeling like
she got her brother back in one division
it's a nice way to give her some payoff
and the fans as well not only would
bringing evan peters across his
quicksilver for realest time somewhat
save the one big problem that fans have
with one division but it will also make
wonder herself at least get a win for
once let's be honest she's not really
had a good time as of late and not only
did she lose the love of her life but
she also lost her kids one division
ended with wonder reading through the
dark hold on the astral plane and here
she could hear the voices of her
children crying out i think that once
she discovers that the multiverse is
open that she'll try and go through it
in order to find a universe in which her
family exists this could also lead to
her attempting to get pietro back and
along with evan peters i'd love to see
aaron taylor johnson playing the
character too let's be honest his
character was pretty underused in age of
ultron and he was completely
overshadowed by peter's version who
debuted in days of future past the same
year peter's version had one of the best
scenes in a comic book movie ever and
with taylor johnson's being killed off
he never really got to shine in the role
i think that this is the perfect movie
to bring him back in and it would also
bring somewhat closer to wonder who came
close to having him back in one division
but it was of course played by peters
now if you bring mutants fully into the
mcu i think that you also have to bring
in several of the x-men from the other
films i'd absolutely love to see hugh
jackman back as wolverine and he's
honestly probably the most requested
actor to come into the mcu in the run-up
to avengers end game there was almost a
video a week talking about how he was
definitely gonna be in the film but
jackman denied it and i for one believe
him i've seen the movie like seven times
and i don't think that he was in it
though he might be as i was pretty drunk
for the last five years however he has
stated several times that he's hung up
the claws for good and with logan being
such a good send-off it might be the
right way for the actor to go however
i'm spoiled as [ __ ] i like seeing people
come back no matter how good their
send-off is jackman is wolverine and if
you're one of the people that saw
reminiscence then you'll know the guy
looks good enough to still pull this off
he's easily at the top of my wish list
and he's an actor i think fans
definitely would love to see come back
as weapon x it could also usher in the
return of x23 and potentially even bring
across his son dakin the both of which
could end up taking on the mantle of
wolverine in the mcu now if you cast
your mind back to last year it was
announced that the illuminati will be
making an appearance and with us
potentially traveling into other
dimensions we could be getting them in
case you don't know they were introduced
in the comics in the lead-up to civil
war and their members include tony stark
professor x black bolt black panther
reed richards and dr strange we already
know from the trailer in toy leaks that
we are getting variants of strange in
the film and i'd love to see the other
lineup filled by different actors if
professor rex is in the movie then you
basically have a choice between james
mcavoy or patrick stewart the both of
which i think were excellent in the role
if we're going to see him in the mcu for
a number of films i think that mcavoy
would be the safer one to go with as
he's a lot younger and you probably want
x in the franchise for a long time
however before i get called aegis
patrick stewart hasn't really showed any
signs of slowing down and he's probably
the person that people think of first
when imagining professor x i remember
back in middle school when i first got
announced that he would be playing the
role my mate chris you know the lad he
said it was obvious casting but i think
that's why it's so perfect the guy
completely embodies the role and it
would be amazing to see him show up now
stuart has discussed meeting with kevin
feige in the past and he said that he
turned down the opportunity to reprise
the role because of logan he said that
that was how he wanted to say goodbye to
the character so he may not show up but
we'll just have to wait and see now if
you're enjoying the theory so far then
please hit the thumbs up button and also
don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this every day i'd love to hear
your wish list on who you think will pop
up as well so make sure you drop them in
the comments below right now do it now
you i'm using my professor x powers and
you will do it now
now with the illuminati also having mr
fantastic in it i'd absolutely love to
see john krasinski showing up in the
role he's someone that fans have wanted
for a long time and every time that
reader is brought up he's the first name
that people put forward krazynski just
fits the role so well without having to
stretch it would be some good news to
see him doing it and at it is his
real-life wife emily blunt also seems
perfect casting for sue in case you
don't know she was actually in the
running for black widow but she couldn't
commit to the role and thus scott joe
ended up taking it instead i think the
pair of them being together in a film as
marvel's first family would be perfect
and seeing both her and krazynski in the
mcu is reading sioux would just work so
well in my opinion marvel are all about
giving the fans what they want and i
think the pair playing the roles are
just so burned into people's heads right
now that if they cast anyone else it
would seem like a disappointment now as
you guys know we get sent a lot of
leaked images and i actually received
one today that looks like emily blum
playing sue richards in a full costume
we're gonna show it right now but yeah
if you don't want that ruined then skip
ahead to the next part of the video
drumroll please
get it because she's the invisible woman
hey you have a lot we have we have a
laugh at the channel we do [ __ ] now with
the idea of several universes popping up
it is possible that we could also
somewhat get a play on the age of
ultron's storyline that comes from the
comic books in that wolverine ended up
breaking the timeline and he was brought
into an alternate marvel universe in
which several things had changed instead
of the avengers we had the defenders as
the main group and this was headed up by
doctor strange the action figure that
has been displayed from the movie is
called defender strange and potentially
if you slow down the trailer you can
catch his ponytail this makes me think
we could be getting members of the
defenders from the age of ultron
timeline and tony stark was also one of
them now whilst it would be great to see
robert downey jr back and actually love
to see tom cruise taking up the mantle
as you might remember he was originally
in line to play iron man all the way
back in the 90s would just be a neat
little bit of fan service and so far
cruz hasn't appeared in any comic book
movies which is a surprise especially
because of how high profile he is beyond
that though i also hope that we get
captain carter who debuted in what if
hayley atwell did a really good job in
the role and though she's not really
been in that many marvel movies i think
that she definitely left a huge
impression and is arguably one of the
best love interests we've had i want to
see things go beyond that though and for
us together playing captain carter in
live action as she's one of the
standouts from what if her bearing the
shield brings a whole new dimension to
it and it's definitely something that i
think we will be getting other picks
would be magneto and they of course need
to bring deadpool into the universe
which i think this film could open the
door for beyond that though i'd love to
see toby mcguire return as spider-man in
this film and potentially even andrew
garfield maguire especially is of course
closely tied to sam raimi and there are
rumors that he was actually brought in
by marvel studios to help get toby on
board for no way home i think it'll be a
big opportunity missed if they don't at
least somewhat get the pair working
together again and this would be the
project to do it in now what i love
about the multiverse of madness and the
comic book movie industry right now is
that it feels like anyone can come back
we're truly living in an age where any
character could return so i'd of course
love to hear your thoughts and who you'd
like to see show up in the film drop
them below and as a thank you we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of an mc boxer
of your choice on the 30th of january
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is to like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so if that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the moonlight trailer
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over all the easter eggs in
it and talked about the character just
in case you don't know who he is so
definitely go check it out right after
this without the way hope to see over
there thanks for sticking through this
video i mean paul you been the best you
take care yourself peace